hello and welcome to our talk on google
cloud golden path to application
delivery my name is victor salve i'm a
product manager and i work in the devops
space at google cloud i'm joined by my
colleague chris willis
hi my name is chris willis and i'm a
customer engineer at google cloud i'm
really focused on helping our customers
succeed with kubernetes and helping
people build and run cloud native
applications at scale
so chris and i are going to talk to you
all today about application development
with this specific focus on kubernetes
so we're going to look at developer
tools and ci cd which are often a pain
point for organizations but really are
also an essential part of the journey i
think many of you know the benefits of
ci cd but just to kind of recap quickly
you know it increases developer
productivity and that's directly linked
to customer value generation
and getting that value out to customers
faster
means you're more competitive you're
scoring higher customer satisfaction
with your customers
and
with better automation and pipeline
parity comes higher quality and security
but we understand that you know you are
where you are right and ci cd and devops
improvements need to happen
incrementally and with your existing
tools and processes
so they say that proof is in the pudding
right and our research highlights that
elite performers the ones who ship code
multiple times per day are 1.8 times
more likely to achieve or exceed their
commercial goals
including things like profitability
productivity
and customer satisfaction
but our research also shows that
organizations are increasingly
successful at adopting cicd so more and
more of you out there are going the path
of ci cd and are seeing those improved
business outcomes as a result
so you know you may be here on your ci
cd journey right
developers are iterating and committing
code which then feeds into a ci cd
pipeline
and ultimately end products are
delivered out to your customers but
you're also faced with some challenges
and for some of you that includes
self-managing your ci cd infrastructure
also bespoke and complicated
configuration pipelines
there's often weak separation of duties
and concerns when it comes to ci cd
systems
and often those ci cd systems are
overused
they're doing build and test but they're
also doing the kitchen sink
and lastly there are variances between
developer and deployment environments
which surface as unwelcome surprises in
production
so
this ultimately leads to fud
right and from the
operations side of the house
we're talking about fear of deployment
you know are developers really iterating
in production like kubernetes
environments are they even adopting
kubernetes um
and when they are
is the innovation they're doing around
rendering tools affecting things like
pipeline reliability
chris
yeah this this is really why i jumped at
the opportunity to get involved with the
golden path
so some of the customers i've worked
with struggle to get their developers to
work directly with kubernetes just
because they they have their development
workflow you know they're they have
their local docker container deployments
and they're used to testing against that
and just kind of working like that and
it's really uh something that they don't
they're not interested in changing and
it makes sense because operators were
really sold on uh
on kubernetes when it exploded in
popularity but in some cases developers
haven't really followed suit you know
they really weren't in the room when
that jump to kubernetes was made and
they're kind of now just being told to
deal with it essentially
yeah and that i think there's also
impact for
for the security side of the house right
a lot of uncertainty there you know is
there enough automation to go around for
things like security analysis and
vetting before things go out the door or
are we relying on manual processes for
that vetting
and
you know also are we finding these
security issues too late in the
development cycle causing a lot of churn
so there's a lot of fun and what we
wanted to do here was present um a
pathway that's been built out and
derived from
a lot of the learnings that we've taken
at google internally
so we identified the following three
concepts and as i mentioned these have
helped our developers stay productive
internally while enabling automation at
scale
so the first one is to decouple and
insulate from configuration change
so kubernetes manifest rendering
it's often tightly coupled with ci cd
pipelines and that really creates sort
of almost like a gridlock situation
where
both sides you know developers working
in their rendering
workflows and operations with their ci
cd pipelines they're hesitant to make
moves they don't want to break
each other so to speak
and so instead we want to separate out
configuration and we want to separate
out the responsibility model
next is unification of the dev
experience
and what i mean here is across the
developer inner loop the ci cd loop
but also all the way out to production
kubernetes clusters
you know the biggest pain developers
face in kubernetes development is
knowing the quarks and variances across
the various loops
so in the inner loop you might be using
something like mini cube
in ci cd there may be some slightly
different environment and ultimately
your
production enterprise kubernetes
environments those might be different
altogether and i'm talking about things
like the use of different environmental
variables
um perhaps different secrets
replicas and so on
so what i really want is a way to bridge
these variances and provide a more
seamless experience
to to all my developers
and the last point here is shifting left
it wastes a lot of developer energy and
nerves frankly
when policy or security constraints are
discovered downstream
so what we want to do is actually inject
those policy checks right into the ide
to catch those issues before devs spend
too much time down a certain pathway
so
we're excited to share with you today
the notion of the golden path for
application delivery on google cloud
now the key to the golden path
is a product called scaffold scaffold is
an open source command line utility that
unifies
the developer experience with
build deploy test security and provides
a uniform experience across all of those
loops
you can use scaffold with your existing
tools
but it's also of course bundled with the
google cloud tools you see here
and while you may be familiar with cloud
code and cloud build we're really
excited to introduce cloud deploy
our fully managed opinionated continuous
delivery service purpose built with
google kubernetes engine in mine
chris you have any thoughts to add on
this
yeah i just i wanted to highlight a few
things here so for those of you that are
not familiar with cloud code it's an
extension of vs code in
intellijs or or it is an extension uh
that is produced for these these ids so
there's no real switching between ids
you don't have to change your id just
because uh you're using cloud code it's
it's baked right into your
ide the cloud code run on kubernetes
feature really clearly delineates where
the developer's responsibility ends and
ops begins
this means developers can really focus
on writing code and not trading ammo
files and troubleshooting surprises when
deploying to staging so this is really
that shift left mentality that victor
was talking about
and then
integration with scaffolds uh you know
it being an open source project means
ops can really start developing an
opinionated approach to ci cd i know
with the introduction of kubernetes
which is really a platform to build
platforms it's not a platform itself
there's a lack of opinions so
on build and deploy so
this can scaffold can really help you
build those opinions and carry them to
other cloud vendors so you're not locked
into google cloud i mean obviously
google cloud integrates heavily with
scaffold
and we're going to make that a first
class experience but you can take the
scaffold container image and run that
same scaffold configuration elsewhere so
you're not really locked into our
services
yeah and chris at the beginning we
talked a lot about incremental adoption
and sort of the the reality of making
changes to your ci cd pipelines you know
we want to encourage all of you to
really start with your most urgent need
and for many of our customers
they've got a development loop going
they've got ci going but cd is the next
frontier and so
you know perhaps you can get the
benefits of scaffold in the golden path
by adopting something like cloud deploy
as a fantastic starting point
or perhaps you can start with cloud code
as chris mentioned this is an ide plugin
which bundles scaffold and it provides a
graphical user experience on top of the
scaffold cli
chris anything else you want to add
about
cloud code
yeah i mean the coolest thing about this
one is that it's free so developers and
operators can you know right after the
session go grab cloud code and there's
no dependency on google cloud we have
sample apps that you can just that'll
just work out of the box you'll click
the run on kubernetes feature and bam
it's deployed to to minicube so it's a
really cool powerful tool uh that
hopefully y'all will check out after
this
yeah the last one you know here is
perhaps cloud build if you're looking
for a fully managed building continuous
integration platform
cloudbuild offers a scaffold builder
which
easily integrates scaffold into your
continuous integration workflow
so chris um i think the best way to
experience the golden path is to see it
in action and
um
what do you think should we should we
get into the demo
yeah let's do it
all right here we go
all right so i just have a basic go
application here and we're gonna use
scaffold in it to generate our
deployment manifests our kubernetes
deployment manifest and our scaffold dml
and these are both going to be applied
against mini cube we'll add a
test here real quick
but i want to break down this scaffold
dml
so we have a build step which is
actually going to build our image and
we're using build packs because we're
going from source you'll notice there's
no docker file here
and a test step which is just going to
run a simple go test inside the
container image
and a deployment manifest where our
kubernetes deployment is defined and
this is all on minicube so it's just
going to pull uh whatever docker image
resolves there
for go mod image
right so now we're going to use that run
on kubernetes button that we had talked
about previously
this is going to execute the scaffold
dml steps and
use the deployment
manifest that we generated to deploy to
minicube
and we'll go and check out our
application
just a very simple
go application
refresh it in the counter increments
so now we want to make a change to our
application to have that quick feedback
as a developer so we want to make a
local change and and see if it works so
we're just going to change this color
from blue to red i know nothing nothing
huge
[Music]
and we see file synced as soon as we
saved it scaffold picks up on that
change locally
and here we go we have a red instead of
a blue application very important
all right let's stop it here
and
obviously debugging is important so this
is my favorite feature
so let's go down and insert a break
point looks like we had one left over
but insert a break point at line
81 right where the counter increments
and click debug on kubernetes this time
instead of run on kubernetes
so this will actually inject a debugger
into the container
and forward those events this is all
part of scaffold for those events to the
ide
and so when we refresh this page it's
going to drop us right into
the debug output we can search through
local variables here
and we can go into the call stack and
look at all sorts of things troubleshoot
you know
certain things about our application
that might
have gone wrong
[Music]
we can resume we can step over all the
normal debug stuff so
very important for developers to be able
to
to debug their applications
so right now we have this dev inner loop
the dev is working through cloud code
deploying locally using minicube
they have their application deployed and
they're working away at it so now the
ops folks are going to go
and create a cloud build trigger which
anytime there is a
a pr pulled into master or some change
to master this is going to fire off
and
execute those scaffold steps that we
specified
and so now we have
uh
anytime the developer pushes to get or
pr is approved cloud build will trigger
all right so you'll see we've added some
things to our scaffold manifest we have
a profile named staging which will
deploy the
deployment staging
manifest which is we just copied the
deployment manifest that we generated
earlier with scaffold in it and added
whatever is specific to staging we did
the exact same for canary and prod and
this is very important because these are
going to
stretch across into
what cloud deploy is later going to use
to deploy to the various uh staging
canary and prod environments they're
they're kind of like scopes right you're
you're trying to get across uh how
this tool should behave or how this
deployment should behave uh in a
different environment which is where we
talked about kind of
the applying of opinions
and making an opinionated cicd process
that sticks with scaffold and not the
cloud providers specific tools
we have our pipeline yaml where we're
specifically saying
what the stages of the pipeline are so
we have staging canary and prod
and for those stages in the pipeline so
each one in the cloud deploy interface
you'll see it'll create kind of a box as
it visualizes the pipeline for each one
you're saying i want you to use this
scaffold profile called staging so this
is where scaffold and cloud deployment
cloud deploy meet
is that you're specifying a specific
step in the pipeline and what scaffold
profile should run
then we have the actual configuration
for the staging step in the pipeline so
remember in the last file we specified
that there was a step in the pipeline
called staging this is where we're going
to say okay staging you're going to use
this uh
google cloud project
this cluster name called staging and
then obviously the the region that it's
in
now we're going to
create the pipeline in cloud deploy
we are going to configure the staging
step in cloud deploy
using those files we just
discussed
and then we're going to trigger the
pipeline
all right so
go to the cloud build interface
and we will check
the build triggering here
it's going to go and do
all those scaffold steps that we've
defined
and we'll go into cloud deploy check out
the pipeline
this will trigger
and do the actual deploy
as we've specified
we'll go and check on our application
and here it is running
so the developers now
working in their inner loop they submit
a pr
an operator approves it cloud build
triggers because master was changed
the
artifact is built and stored in artifact
registry and then the associated
staging process in the cloud deploy
pipeline is triggered and a deployment
to staging is initiated
and we're going to promote that staging
release we deployed we're going to
promote it to a canary deploy
and that will deploy to prod
right so normal canary deployment it'll
deploy to prod and then if there's
anything wrong you just roll it back and
and hopefully nothing bad happened
so let's make sure that the
app is deployed to the canary are the
canaries deployed correctly
and let's check on the application
looks good we got our little chickadee
there
to signify that it is
canary deployment
and now we will promote
the release from a canary deploy to
prod and there's going to be an extra
step here so
see that it's pending so we know that we
need an approval someone with the
authority to approve this release to
production
not just anyone can push to production
hopefully
and so this person's going to come in
and say okay yeah looks good we're going
to we're going to prove that roll out to
production
and so we'll go back and check on it and
the deployment to prod is
underway
finished
now let's check on our production
application let's make sure everything's
in order
looks good
all right
so our final state
is the developer again working in cloud
code their local loop which can be mini
cube it can be
local can kind of be anywhere that's
what i found out with customers it can
be you know i'm on a laptop and i'm on
an airplane local or it can be i'm just
in my normal gke cluster that someone
made for me and that's where i do my
development
so they're they're doing that dev inner
loop getting that fast feedback
they submit apr to the get repo
and an operator approves the pr
and uh there is a
trigger from cloud build because master
has changed
the artifact is generated stored in
artifact registry and the associated
staging pipeline step is
run we obviously had an extra canary
deployment step in here
and
once canary tries to go to prod
an operator actually has to come in and
approve that and then you have your
change to prod so that is the full end
to end picture
and that is the end of the demo
all right so let's summarize what we've
seen today
the golden path for application delivery
on google cloud centers around unifying
pipelines across dev ci and cd
we accomplish this with scaffold
scaffold is open source
it's a cli but it's wrapped in a ui
provided by cloud code
it helps developers get productive with
local kubernetes development and
debugging
right within the ide
but scaffold also creates pipeline
parity
by
commands that fit right into your ci and
cd processes
you can adopt this approach
incrementally starting with only those
components that you need most
so here are some resources that we've
talked about in today's talk
if you'd like to get started we'd invite
you to check these out
chris
yes that just one thing to note that
github link at the bottom uh is just on
my on my own github but that read me and
and that starter uh application is
exactly what i used in the demo here
today so if you want to try it out on
your own
it'll all work just following the readme
and and generating all of the ammo files
as you go
so feel free to check that out
well that's it for our session i want to
thank my colleague chris for a fantastic
demo
and uh
i want to thank you all for spending
some time with us and learning about the
uh golden path for application delivery
on google cloud
thanks